what do what have you said when people
ask about the morality of this
in that you know people say you're
either playing god but i don't really
care about that
part so much but more of that this is
amazing technology that could be
potentially used in the wrong hands or
wrong purposes or even accidentally be
strange like what do you what do you
what do you guys think of that and
how do we control for that and what are
your thoughts it's hard for me to
imagine a scenario
that's really dark about these
technologies i think the
the the moral issue that people do get
concerned about
is animal welfare and um you know
there are people that feel that it's
immoral to have zoo
animals in captivity period
and so you know i believe
that um more and more zoos worldwide
are very focused on conservation
and in fact they're a major contributor
to conservation because
very often the breeding of those animals
that are done in zoos
then get reintroduced to the wild and so
they're
they play a very important part of that
that conservation ecosystem
it can't happen without those animals in
captivity
so i think it's always a question of do
you care about the
individual animal more than the
collective
population or the collective species as
a whole
and so yes maybe and some animals
may suffer individually through some of
this process
and in some of this experimentation but
if you're doing it
in order to ensure that the population
survives
um i think you got to look at the the
greater good
the the welfare issue is actually why we
use the domestic ferret
um to clone elizabeth and that's why we
use a domestic horse to clone
the wild chevolski's foal is because
domestic species have been living
with human beings for thousands of years
for the purposes we've bred them to do
their welfare is well accounted for
and you know it takes a surrogate mother
it takes an egg donor to make these
animals
um black-footed ferret females are best
used
just breeding more offspring rather than
being donors so if
so that was the big reason why we go to
a domestic species something that we
know we can give really great welfare to
in captivity and then bring a new
valuable animal into
an endangered species but on that zoo
concept that ryan brings up you know
if it wasn't for zoos and captive
breeding black-footed ferrets
condors whooping cranes kakapo would all
be extinct today
the people behind this when you really
meet people working in zoos who do this
and the people doing conservation
animal welfare issues of the individuals
they're at their
their hearts like people bond with these
animals
and and they're doing an amazing job uh
today
unlike any generation before to make
sure that we can save species
without incurring costs like uh but it
but it's true there's a pragmatic aspect
to it that we have to just
at the end of the day say what do we pay
to save a species and what is the value
of an entire species worth
and and in that realm there's a lot of
people have made a very strong moral
obligation argument that because
these species are in trouble from the
things that we did either intentionally
or unintentionally
in ignorance or exploitation
that we have to struggle with paying the
cost
to undo that harm you know we we've
often get this sort of challenging
question of
you know what about the unintended
consequences you know
what if it goes wrong what if science
doesn't get it right
um and uh what we have seen is that this
concept of unintended consequences is
quite paralyzing for society
it basically means don't do anything you
don't fully understand
don't do anything that you know you've
got these unknown unknowns out there
until you answer them you can't proceed
and
we did this amazing workshop and at the
end of the day
it became really clear that if we really
want to
help with the environment right now if
we really want to intervene
we have to actually start designing for
intended consequences
what is it that we want to do that will
be of benefit
as opposed to being paralyzed by the
things that we think
are going to be the greatest risk so
finding that balance is both
a moral cultural economic shift for a
lot of people to think through where do
they put
their time their energy their money for
conservation so the biggest problem in
politics is that we're too scared
well if you do that then what happens
right it's one of the reasons we haven't
done anything on climate change
it's like because we're worried about
hurting the companies or hurting xyz or
changing things like well the reality is
we're melting the planet so we better do
something
yeah so what what does the future look
like what and
like i'd love to talk about two two
pieces that what what's exciting you
and then what what could be scary kind
of about the unintended content what are
the downside risks that could be scary
let's start with what's exciting you
what does this look like 10
20 years from now 50 years from now what
are we looking at before talking about
the next 20 to 50
to 100 years is we're living in an
amazing
future of conservation right now like
getting back to this issue of intended
and unintended consequences
people have been doing intended
conservation for a long time you can
we looked at just one one part of
conservation
just the movement of wildlife from a zoo
to the wild from one location to another
that's been going on for 125 years in
the united states
and the track record is
99.99999
successfully beneficial unintended
consequences that people have feared for
decades and continue to fear
just haven't bore out like the fear that
they won't integrate
the tiger won't integrate back into the
wild exactly these fears have not bore
out
and and uh and so looking to the future
if we look at just right now compared to
where we were
at the beginning of conservation and you
think of the amazing way we can bring in
biotechnologies
we're living in a in a world that is
proof that conservationists do good work
responsibly they think about the risks
and they mitigate and anticipate those
they save species and we take a lot of
it for granted
you know out here on the east coast
whitetail deer are everywhere
120 years ago they were on the verge of
extinction
and today they are a conservation
success story nobody talks about that
because
that all happened before we ever had an
endangered species act before we were
you know really aware of all this stuff
so the history of conservation
is we're already in it you add
biotechnology to that with the people
behind the wheel that are good drivers
of this
and there's so many amazing things we
could do actually make sure that we
don't lose coral reefs in the next 50
years
bring back species into environments
that are so valuable
that you know that we've never been able
to before that we can rediversify the
planet
keep genetics going and really in my
opinion
create a future where there's equity and
balance in how
humans of every walk of life can enjoy
and live in harmony
every walk of their day with the
millions of other species on this planet
man i love that answer i think i'm
learning here in some ways that in order
to be
in the conservation business you kind of
have to be
some form of an optimist you know
because it's such a forward-looking
futuristic hope for a better future
business industry
yeah think about it oliver ryder
froze the will the cells of willa 33
years ago
with the hope they'd be used someday you
know that's optimism
to its core good point and that's
conservation it's it's about being
pragmatic today
with an optimistic spirit that you're
going to win and you keep working until
you win and i think ryan
you know if i can say for all of us
that's why intended consequences
is such a huge paradigm shift that's
important because
if all you're thinking of is how can
this go wrong and it's going to go wrong
and we're doomed and you think in fear
you give up and conservation has been a
success story of perseverance that
you keep going till you get success
that's how businesses are made that's
how politicians win
uh candidacies that's how we save
species
and biotech is going to give us ways to
do that that we've never had the
ability to do before um and so you know
i would love it if there was a flood of
movies and tv shows that stopped
peddling the dystopian future of
biotechnology
because everyone we know using it is
doing it
to do something amazing and good in this
world
and and so when you ask what are we
scared of or what are the unintended
consequences
i can't think of any that are serious
because
the nature of this field is about doing
something that's going to have benefit
it's such a good point whereas it's
there's so much
there's not a lot of quick wins in your
world you know what i'm saying where
it's like so much work and energy and
trial and error
so like let's talk about like the evil
doer who's the bad guy in avatar who's
mining the new planet for whatever or
you know that's what like human beings
think of when they think of this right
that human in your space is gonna have a
lot of barriers
to prevent them from being the bad guy
because it's so hard
and time consuming um so that actually
is really uplifting
and ultimately zach none of this
technology goes forward
without social license we have a
regulatory environment as soon as you're
working with endangered
species it has to be complied with um
but you know increasingly what we're
hearing
throughout our culture right now is that
um people of all different
walks of life bear relationship to
nature whether it's in their own
backyard or it's out
at the top of a mountain somewhere when
they're skiing
everybody comes at it from a different
perspective and they all
have a common right to care about what's
going on in their environment
allowing those voices to be heard giving
it
permission for them to actually have a
voice
in how we interact with nature
is going to be a real important part of
the equation and it's something that i
think will build in
this patience in a sense that you're
calling for in conservation it can't
happen fast
um you know these species have been on
the planet for thousands
of years and what we want to do is keep
them on this planet
for the next millions of years so to do
that
um we have to have the long the long
term thinking in place the long goal
[Music]
you